général monsieur frédéric veaux de votre
présence cet après midi je crois visite
accompagnée de madame cécile berton qui
est votre directrice de cabinet nous
recevons dans cette salle médicis pour
comme je le disais à l'instant respecté
les règles sanitaires et votre audition
s'inscrit évidemment dans un point de
vue général que nous avions souhaité sur
la sécurité notamment en prévision de ce
texte d'aimé sécurité globale que nous
avons en charge désormais dans cette
maison depuis le 26 novembre dernier
c'est la raison pour laquelle monsieur
daubresse qui en est le rapporteur
bientôt le co-rapporteur avec nos
collègues hervé qui nous rejoindra
sûrement est naturellement présent
et puis notre collègue henri leroy qui
est leur apporter en lui de tous les
sujets des avis budgétaire sur la
sécurité est également présente mais sur
les autres sont là nous sommes aussi
intéressés de vous entendre certes dans
le cadre de ce texte mais pas seulement
puisque le livre blanc de la sécurité
intérieure a été rendue publique il y a
quelques jours pour ne pas dire quelques
semaines d'ailleurs il fait un certain
nombre de propositions et qu'à travers
ces propositions certaines d'ailleurs
qui ont été reprises viennent de cette
maison et du sénat en particulier et
nous en sommes ravis cela dit nous
aimerions en avoir avoir votre point de
vue sur ce sujet l'objet de cette
audition je le rappelle est d'abord
opérationnel pour apprécier ou
appréhender plus d'actes mans les
conditions dans lesquelles aujourd'hui
la police nationale exerce ses missions
il n'était pas prévu mais l'actualité
est ainsi que cette édition soit éclairé
par les événements plus récents que nous
venons de vivre sur le territoire
national à la fois des violences
commises par des personnalités
individuelles la plus nationale sur des
manifestants une polémique qui s'ouvre
sur des sujets liés aux dispositions de
l'article 24 de la loi sus du projet de
22,8 la proposition de loi pardon
relatives à la sécurité globale apporte
évidemment des éléments de contexte qui
font que votre édition a pour nous une
importance grande encore plus grande
elle était déjà naturellement mais
encore plus grand voilà ce que je
souhaitais vous dire en propos de début
de débat en insistant sur un point qui
correspond qui fera en fait ma question
finalement avant de vous laisser la
parole nous entendons nous lisons que
nos policiers n'auraient pas de temps de
formation suffisant qu'il mériterait
d'être peut être formé plus longtemps
peut-être dans leur formation continue
d'être plus souvent
j'allais dire je ne peux pas dire
évaluer ce n'est peut-être pas le terme
mais qu'il y ait une formation continue
plus en plus soutenue voilà je dire les
choses de cette manière là nous
interrogeons sur ce point puisque cela
commence à faire
outre quelques articles de presse c'est
la vérité qui nous intéresse est moins
ce que l'on peut lire ou entendre dire
ici ou là voilà monsieur le directeur
ces quelques propos je vous laisse le
soin de dire ce que vous avez à dire ce
que vous souhaitez nous dire et puis
ensuite je demanderai à nos rapporteur
respectifs et aux collègues qui sont là
de pouvoir vous poser quelques questions
nous sommes donné une heure trente
d'horloge j'essaye de veiller au respect
de ces horaires merci à vous avez la
parole
[Musique]
merci de surprise donc je ne sais pas si
vous souhaitez que je reste aux basques
et où si je pense à visage découvert
monsieur le président mesdames et
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
je vous remercie de me donner
l'opportunité de vous exposer les
attentes de la police nationale dans la
mise en oeuvre des politiques de
sécurité qui mobilise aujourd'hui non
seulement les forces de sécurité
intérieures mais qui doivent également
impliquer davantage les polices
municipales et les acteurs de la
sécurité privée
la police nationale est convaincu de
l'importance de ce continuant de
sécurité et de la nécessité de tisser
localement un partenariat étroit avec
les élus et les citoyens
les policiers municipaux sont dorénavant
des acteurs incontournables de la
sécurité du quotidien il assure une
présence sur la voie publique totalement
complémentaire de celle des policiers
nationaux
ils sont d'ailleurs à ce titre souvent
confrontés aux mêmes risques et je
voudrais avoir une pensée particulière
pour la policière municipale qui avait
été victime d'un attentat terroriste
au cours de cette année 2020 par exemple
les polices municipales ont eu un rôle
déterminant aux côtés des policiers et
des gendarmes pour assurer du respect
des mesures liées à l'état d'urgence
sanitaire et dresser des contraventions
dans le cadre des orientations que leur
donne les maires et des conventions de
coordination que l'état signe avec les
polices municipales des patrouilles
mixtes ou des opérations conjointes sont
régulièrement organisées il existe même
de plus en plus des locaux continuent
entre la police nationale et la police
municipale proposant d accueil commun
quant au centre de supervision urbain
ils sont évidemment un lieu des charges
opérationnelles très précieux entre nos
forces le partage d'information est
essentielle pour la mise en oeuvre des
dispositifs de sécurité dans certaines
grandes villes par exemple des
protocoles ont été signés
afin d'associer officiellement la police
municipale au plan national de lutte
contre les stupéfiants
avec l'envoi des informations des
policiers municipaux à la cellule du
renseignement opérationnel sur les
stupéfiants
les polices municipales participent
également systématiquement au 949 groupe
de partenariats opérationnels
créée dans le cadre de la police de
sécurité du quotidien et vous le savez
ces dispositifs de proximité parviennent
à régler de nombreux problèmes très
concrets ayant trait à la sécurité au
titre des progrès réalisés au cours de
ces dernières années
il convient de souligner
l'interopérabilité permettant depuis
2015 aux policiers municipaux d'être
accueillis sur les réseaux de
radiocommunication des forces de
sécurité intérieure grâce à des
conférences dédiées
enfin depuis le 1er juillet 2019
l'accès des policiers municipaux a été
généralisée à deux fichiers de police de
recife pour les immatriculations des
véhicules et le snpc pour les permis de
conduire
nous pouvons encore aller plus loin dans
l'accès aux fichiers à condition que des
informations communiqués correspondent
évidemment strictement aux nouvelles
prérogatives des polices municipales
je suis par ailleurs très favorable à
étendre les pouvoirs confiés aux
policiers municipaux avec cependant
quelques limites qui me paraissent
essentiels
ils ne doivent pas participer aux
opérations de maintien de l'ordre ni
réaliser des investigations en matière
judiciaire cela signifie que s'il est
pertinent qu'il puisse constater
davantage d'infractions
cela doit se limiter aux faits dont la
matérialisation ne nécessite aucun acte
d' enquête
l'objectif n'est pas en effet de créer
une police concurrente des forces de
sécurité intérieure avec des compétences
croisées mais plutôt de mieux répartir
les tâches entre policiers et gendarmes
d'une part et policiers municipaux
d'autre part dans le but de mobiliser
prioritairement les premiers sur les
missions qui relèvent du régalien
dans ce cadre l'expérimentation de trois
ans dans des communes volontaires et
disposant de police municipale d'au
moins vingt agents après une formation à
laquelle la police nationale pourra
continuer d'apporter son expertise
sera sans doute bien accueillie dans les
commissariats les activités de la
sécurité privée sont en plein
développement
la professionnalisation de ces acteurs
économiques doit retenir toute notre
attention notamment dans la perspective
de l'organisation de la coupe du monde
de rugby en 2023 et des jeux olympiques
et paralympiques en 2024
cette croissance doit s'accompagner de
grains de garanties qui sont prises en
compte dans le texte qui vous est soumis
telles que la limitation de la sous
traitance le renforcement des conditions
d'entrée en profession et le contrôle
la proposition de loi contient également
des dispositions très attendue par les
forces de l'ordre dans le domaine de la
captation d'image qui impose un cadre
juridique solide et respectueux des
libertés publiques
les dispositions prévues permettraient
aux policiers de travailler dans une
totale sécurité juridique avec les
moyens techniques les plus modernes et
selon des modalités qui correspondent à
leurs besoins opérationnels
je pense en premier lieu aux caméras
piétons dont le développement est
attendu par les policiers en quantité et
en qualité qui pourrait renvoyer les
images en temps réel vers les centres de
commandement mais aussi vers d'autres
preneurs policiers sur la voie publique
dans ce registre il me paraît également
indispensable que les policiers puissent
eux-mêmes consulter les images avec les
garanties qu'elle ne puisse pas être
bien sûr altérée par exemple pour
relever du numéro d'une plaque
d'immatriculation qui leur auraient
échappé pendant l'action de la même
façon le cadre juridique proposé pour
usage des drones est conforme à nos
besoins opérationnels
par exemple pour apporter un appui aux
personnels au sol dans le cadre d'une
magnifique d'une manifestation pour
constater des infractions ou pour
réguler des flux de transport dans ce
champ de la captation d'image des
garanties parfaitement justifiées sont
prévues pas de modification des images
pas de captation des lieux privés durée
limitée de conservation outre
l'engagement à les respecter strictement
nombreux dispositifs techniques peuvent
nous y aider depuis les attentats de
les policiers sont autorisés à porter
leurs armes hors service s'ils en font
la demande
en effet l'article r 400 34-19 du celle
ci dispose que lorsque les circonstances
le requiert le policier ou le gendarme
même lorsqu'il n'est pas en service
intervient de sa propre initiative
avec les moyens dont ils disposent
notamment pour porter assistance aux
personnes en danger
l'actualité nous rappelle régulièrement
la pertinence de cette mesure
or il est malheureusement arrivé que des
policiers se voient interdire l accès à
une salle de spectacle ou un stade en
raison du port de leur arme de service
il est donc nécessaire de pouvoir
remédier à cette difficulté la
protection des policiers est un sujet
qui je le crois
nos soucis tous nous avons encore en
mémoire l'assassinât barbare de deux
fonctionnaires de police
jessica schneider et jean baptiste
salvin chez eux à magnanville le 13 juin
cette affaire a profondément marqué les
policiers un couple assassinés à leur
domicile uniquement parce qu'ils étaient
policiers
les exemples sont malheureusement de
plus en plus nombreux
d'agressions physiques et verbales à
l'encontre des policiers principalement
dans l'accomplissement de leur mission
mais aussi dans leur cadre privé en
raison de leur qualité est pire parfois
à l'encontre de leur famille
la chose qui m'a le plus frappé depuis
que j'ai pris mes fonctions le 3 février
dernier
c'est le niveau de violence et le nombre
d'agressions qui touche les policiers
même dans des territoires que nous
pourrions croire préserver dernier
exemple en date
à cahors le week-end dernier les
policiers aspirent légitimement à ce que
leur sécurité soit assurée leur anonymat
garanti et leurs familles protéger des
conséquences de leur activité
professionnelle
leur attente est donc forte en ce
domaine sans pour autant réclamer ou
imaginer que la liberté d'informer soit
de quelques façons remise en cause
je souhaitais également évoqué comme le
fait monsieur le président rapidement la
contribution très intéressante du livre
blanc sur la sécurité intérieure qui a
été rendu public par le ministre de
l'intérieur le 14 novembre dernier
ces travaux se sont appuyés sur une
large concertation en interne au
ministère de l'intérieur mais aussi
auprès des acteurs du continuum de
sécurité d'élus vous l'avez rappelé et
de représentants de la société civile
même si les quelques 200 propositions de
ce livre blanc n'ont peut-être pas
toutes vocation à être appliqué ce
document est une source d'inspiration
qui comporte des recommandations très
complète et concrète
par exemple sur le continuum de sécurité
ou sur l'organisation de la police
nationale s'agissant des polices
municipales et de la sécurité privée
les préconisations sont d'ailleurs
totalement en phase avec le contenu de
la proposition de la proposition de loi
pour une sécurité globale des
propositions ont d'ores et déjà donné
lieu à une mise en oeuvre comme le
développement de la politique de
sécurité du quotidien le schéma national
du maintien de l'ordre
annoncé en septembre 2020 et le plan
national de lutte contre les stupéfiants
confiant le rôle de chef de file au
nouvel office spécialisé l'office en
ch'ti stupéfiants de nombreux travaux
restent à mener concernant la police
nationale dont l'organisation qui est
parfois qualifiée de tuyaux d'orgue nuit
à son efficience et à l'émergence d'une
stratégie globale
le ministre de l'intérieur a souhaité
l'expérimentation au début de l'année
2000 21 2 3 direction unifiée de la
police nationale les directions
territoriales de la police nationale ou
les directions des partis
mental de la police nationale dans trois
départements le pas de calais les
pyrénées orientales et la savoie 3d tpn
sont depuis un an
expérimenté en outre-mer et les premiers
résultats sont très encourageants dans
le prolongement du livre blanc sur la
sécurité intérieure
le ministre de l'intérieur nous a
demandé avec le directeur général de la
gendarmerie nationale de réfléchir à une
meilleure articulation de nos services
sur le territoire
rien n'est encore défini précisément ce
travail doit s'appuyer sur une
évaluation des redéploiements antérieurs
dont les derniers ont été réalisés en
2014 mesdames les sénatrices messieurs
les sénateurs avant de répondre à vos
questions
comme vous me avait invité monsieur le
président je ne peux pas ne pas faire
référence aux derniers événements qui
ont atteint la police nationale sans les
évoquer cependant puisque des enquêtes
judiciaires sont en cours
je vous le dis avec beaucoup de force et
beaucoup de conviction celle d'un homme
qui est entré dans la police en 1982 et
qu'il a quittée pendant quatre années
pour exercer les fonctions de préfet de
département
j'ai la faiblesse de penser que je
connais bien cette belle institution et
les hommes et les femmes qui s'y
dévouent la police n'est pas violente
alors même qu'elle est confrontée en
première ligne à la violence comme
aucune autre structure dans notre pays
la police n'est pas violente et n'est
pas raciste
en vous disant cela je ne suis pas dans
le déni et dans la langue de bois je
vous livre ce que je vois et ce que
j'entends je croise quotidiennement les
regards de policiers qui sont le reflet
est l'expression de notre société comme
peu d'institutions peuvent en faire état
des hommes et des femmes courageux
professionnels et volontaires qui
répondent toujours
présente dans les moments les plus
difficiles dans ce métier compliqué qui
conduit beaucoup de policiers sur la
voie publique
vous pouvez partir en patrouille et vous
retrouvez à intervenir sur une action
très violente et j'ai en mémoire le
l'exemple de l'assassinât monstrueux de
samuel pâti à conflans des effectifs de
la sécurité publique de cette
circonscription étaient en patrouille et
en quelques minutes
malgré le caractère épouvantable de
cette scène de crime ont réagi et ont pu
neutraliser l'auteur de cet assassinat
dans les conditions les plus
professionnelles vous à vous avez beau
avoir été sélectionnée former équiper
encadré arrive le moment de la décision
du geste vous allez devoir faire en un
quart de seconde
c'est ce qui rend ce métier passionnant
mais aussi exigeant et exploser car vous
engagez énormément de choses avec la
décision que vous prenez dans ce
contexte certains heureusement très peu
nombreux mais malheureusement encore
trop nombreux
ces gars en commettant des actes
contraires à la loi et où au code de
déontologie
la police nationale les sanctionne
sévèrement à la suite d' enquêtes
conduites par l'igpn bouc émissaire un
peu trop facile dans ces circonstances
et par les groupes spécialisés en charge
des affaires disciplinaires relevant des
directions active
face à ces situations j'ai une double
exigence tirer toutes les conséquences
de ses actes et sanctionner les
comportements contraires à nos lois nos
valeurs et au pacte républicain adapter
nos méthodes et nos pratiques
je vous le redis avec force la violence
et le racisme n'ont pas leur place dans
la police je vous le dis avec confiance
car j'ai beaucoup d'estimé et de
considération et de reconnaissance
pour les policiers que j'ai le privilège
de diriger vous pouvez aussi leur faire
confiance
mesdames les sénatrices mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
la tâche de la police nationale est rude
vaste dans un univers qui se complexifie
et dont tous ceux qui ne veulent pas
respecter nos règles savent saisir les
opportunités
nous avons donc besoin de l'aide de tous
dans cette dynamique du continuum de
sécurité où chacun trouvera sa place
sans empiéter sur les compétences de
l'autre merci monsieur le directeur
je vais donner la parole aux collègues
qui le souhaite peut être lourd à porter
qui de monsieur daubresse de monsieur
hervé souhaite exprimer
monsieur daubresse oui monsieur le
président monsieur le directeur général
je dois vous dire que j'adhère tout à
fait à la fin de votre propos est qu
étant moi même fils d'un inspecteur
principal devenu commissaire
divisionnaire de police
je peux voir l'évolution des choses
entre ce qu'était sa fonction qui était
déjà rude à l'époque et la violence qui
s'exprime aujourd'hui et que vous
trouverez je pense pas trahir la pensée
de mes collègues beaucoup de soutien
pour que l'on puisse garantir la
protection des policiers qui dans leur
immense majorité font très bien leur
travail se concentrera à mes questions
sur deux choses les évolutions prévues
dans la loi sécurité globale sur les
polices municipales et puis bien sûr
l'article 24 donc qu'elle le président
buffet a fallu ions et mon collègue et
hervé vous parlera plus des questions de
images drones caméra autoportée etc
que vous avez évoqué vous même sur la
question des des polices municipales
vous nous avez expliqué que vous aviez
déjà ce que le cas vivement beaucoup
d'action commune avec police nationale
police municipale des locaux contigus
des conventions de coopération est ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire plus pour
évaluer aujourd'hui la coopération entre
eux police nationale gendarmerie
nationale et police municipale
combien ça représente de conventions de
coordination est ce qu'elles sont
actuellement obligatoire pour les sols
municipe police municipale de plus de
trois agents la difficulté qu'on aime
comprenez bien dans la proposition de
loi qui nous arrive l'assemblée
nationale c'est qu'il n'ya pas d'étude
d'impact
il n'y a pas eu d'avis du conseil d'état
donc nous posons un certain nombre de
questions nous n'avons pas toujours de
réponse
et quelle est votre appréciation plus
globale sur l'expérimentation proposé
est ce qu elle vous paraît de nature à
alléger les tâches des policiers et des
gendarmes
et comment vous voyez la montée en
puissance des polices municipales et
comment vous voyez le cadrage de moi
j'ai été maire pendant trente ans si
vous savez donc j'ai dirigé une police
municipale le maire il n'est pas inné
bon certes il a un titre d'officier de
police judiciaire mais il n'est pas sous
l'autorité du procureur de la république
donc quand il ya des interpellations qui
se font quand on élargit les compétences
si on perd mais ce quelqu'un dans la loi
de sécurité globale d'intervenir par
exemple sur des constats de de
possession de stupéfiants tout ça pose
des problèmes juridiques importants vous
vous avez je pense aujourd'hui tout ça
est très stabilisé entre la police et le
procureur tout ça se fait sous contrôle
ce avec des pv qui sont transmis comment
vous voyez pas ce que pour
opérationnellement c'est compliqué quand
même parce que quelque part ça peut pas
être un procès verbal fait par un
policier municipal souvent pas assez
formés qui permet de gérer ce genre de
chose un formalisme que
on prévoit de faire par les directeurs
des polices municipales quand ils
existent
comment vous voyez les choses
opérationnellement ccc ma question
et puis le miz intérieur il a fait
allusion lui même hier à l'assemblée
nationale sur le président buffet aussi
sur le nécessaire renforcement de la
formation des agents de police
municipale
je suis complètement en phase avec tout
ça pourquoi avoir constaté
opérationnellement qui avait quand même
beaucoup de failles dans la formation
juridique des policiers municipaux même
si leur formation technique et sportive
et et bien parachever mais la formation
initiale ne semble présenter des lacunes
évidemment que vous pouvez jouer un rôle
vous devez jouer un rôle important dans
tout ça ça c'est mes principales
questions sur la police municipale jean
vient sur l'article 24 qui comme vous le
savez est un article qui eux qui créent
une infraction de diffusion du visage ou
de tout élément d'identification dans le
but qu'il soit porté atteinte à
l'intégrité physique ou psychique
lorsqu'il agit dans le cadre d'une
opération de police comment peut-on
caractériser un délit d'intention qui
n'existe pas en droit français comment
peut-on porter atteinte à une intégrité
psychique
même si on voit bien l'objectif de
l'arctique est quand même de répondre à
cette horrible affaire de magnanville en
particulier mais qui caractérise bien
d'autres faits sur la violence de la
mise en examen de certains policiers sur
les réseaux sociaux
quelles sont les difficultés que vous
rencontrez actuellement pour empêcher ou
réprimer la diffusion malveillante des
données personnelles des agents
d'intervention est ce que vous pensez
que le texte envisagé
[Musique]
il répond est ce que vous pensez à
contrario que le texte qui est envisagée
puisque malheureusement on est dans
cette que confusion et interpénétration
de textes sur ce que l'article 25 du
projet de loi désormais appeler valeurs
de la république qui couvre le même
domaine et ce qu'ils iraient pour mieux
s qu'il fallait faire une incrimination
via le droit de la presse ou est ce
qu'il fallait faire une incrimination
via le code pénal
si on le fait via le code pénal les
sanctions encourues sont beaucoup plus
fortes
bon je vous demande pas évidemment de
répondre de manière politique c'est le
rôle du ministère mais comment vous
opérationnellement vous pensez qu'on
atteint bien sûr que nous sommes tous en
face pour mieux protéger les policiers
en particulier mais aussi d'autres
agents du service public
comment pour pensez vous qu'on puisse
atteindre au mieux les objectifs
recherchés à travers ces deux écritures
qui existent aujourd'hui celle du 24 de
la sécurité globale et celle du 25 qui
va arriver prochainement puisqu'elle
passe au conseil des messieurs 9
décembre et prochainement conseil d'état
je reviens pas sur le reste parce que il
y aurait tellement de questions à poser
mais c'est l'essentiel merci ça va
peut-être monsieur loïc hervé dussel
daytona bien volontiers monsieur le
président merci monsieur le directeur
général en complément des questions
posées l'instant par marc philippe
daubresse
je voudrais - ma tâche est une question
vous avez déjà touché du doigt dans
votre intervention concernant concernant
les drones
concernant son utilisation actuelle par
les services de la police nationale par
son régime juridique actuel et à
supposer que évidemment la loi lui donne
un régime plus robuste et est-ce que
vous pouvez nous donner avec des
exemples chiffrés ou des des exemples
concrets la manière dont ces drones sont
utilisés dans les différentes missions
de la police nationale le maintien de
l'ordre d'une part mais également
d'autres d'autres d'autres missions et
par ailleurs est ce qu'il y à une un
régime juridique différent ou et s'il ya
un régime juridique différent à voir
avec les caméras gyroscopique utilisez
sur des hélicoptères qui peuvent sur des
événements notamment de maintien d'ordre
être utilisé avec j'imagine un opérateur
qui doit être dans l'appareil et qui
peut être amenée à filmer un certain
nombre d'événements en cours et allait
retransmettre à vos personnes sur le sur
le terrain ensuite sur les les caméras
les caméras mobiles quels retours
d'expériences pouvez vous faire de ses
premières années d'utilisation
on sait qu'il ya pas mal de pas mal de
retours en égard à la qualité de ses de
ces caméras notamment la question des
batteries qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire est ce qu'on arriverait à voir
une solution technique beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus solide et beaucoup
peut-être une solution technique
d'ailleurs nationales ou européennes
permettant aussi de développer des des
équipements qu'ils soient des
équipements souverain et qui ne ne fasse
pas être dépendant seulement de produits
fabriqués en asie en afrique en asie du
sud-est et enfin sur l'article 22 bis
donc qui concerne les caméras embarquées
dans les véhicules
quelle est la pratique actuelle et quel
est le cadre juridique actuel est celui
que vous que vous préconisez pour ses
camarades qui sont dans l'est
essentiellement sur le tableau de bord
des véhicules je remercie ses fans
important peut-être mais c'est henri
leroy et puis ensuite je serai la parole
pour réponse oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le directeur
votre intervention s'inscrit dans la
philosophie du livre blanc on l'a bien
senti dans tous les développements
notamment qui concerne la police l'union
gendarmerie police nationale police
municipale
vous avez parlé de la formation vous
avez parlé du recrutement très
sincèrement aujourd'hui quand on voit
comment sont traités les policiers
est ce bien de leur faute monsieur le
directeur général en ce sens que il est
vrai que les forces de sécurité sont
employés sur des missions dont ils n'ont
pas la formation
on sait très bien que la formule la
formation initiale a été raccourci de
huit mois 12
il y à une crise du recrutement ou
effectivement fut un temps il y avait
six fois plus de candidats pour un poste
qu'il y en a pratiquement aujourd'hui et
ils n'ont quasiment plus le temps de
faire une formation continue et vous en
avez parlé cette formation n'est pas
satisfaisante même pour la voie publique
alors qu'on emploie de plus en plus des
formations qui ne sont pas formés à la
technique du maintien de l'ordre qui est
une technique particulière qui est une
technique qui s'apprend dans les écoles
on voit bien que que ce soit les deux
formations spécialisées dans le maintien
de l'ordre
la gendarmerie mobile et les crs n'ont
pas sont pas souvent impliqués dans ce
qu'on a appelé injustement les violences
policières parce que ce sont des
violences de policiers ou de gendarmes
mais ce ne sont pas des violences
policières parce que violences
policières consiste à incriminer toutes
les deux corporations
vous parlez aussi de la police
municipale et du continuum de sécurité
c'est pour cela que je dis
effectivement que ça s'inscrit
totalement dans le livre blanc alors il
y à une question qui intéresse vraiment
tous les élus et notamment les maires
qui sont les élus de proximité qui
recrutent équipes et les polices
municipales
est ce que il est envisagé parce que je
vais pas trouver dans la lecture du
livre blanc où il ya un grand chapitre
sur le rapprochement des forces de
sécurité il n'est pas marqué exactement
de façon très claire
quels seront les tasses qui seront
dévolus à la police municipale
si ce sont les tâches indues aujourd'hui
supporté par la police nationale et la
gendarmerie
les maires qui sont les porteurs
financier de recrutement comme je disais
ne seront certainement pas d'accord pour
s'inscrire dans cette revente îles à
sion et cette union des forces
et puis je voudrais aussi vous dire que
aujourd'hui d'employer ces gens là dans
des missions extrêmement spécialisé où
la violence effectivement s'exprime de
façon intolérable vis-à-vis de la police
nationale vis-à-vis des forces de
sécurité engagées à ma question surtout
parce que cette formation n'est pas
n'est pas n'est pas satisfaisante
nous l'avons d'ailleurs coucher noir sur
blanc dans le rapport qui a été fait
suite à la commission d' enquête qui a
été réalisée pendant six mois au contact
du terrain au contact de tous les
responsables au contact des policiers
des syndicats par le sénat et qui a été
remis au premier ministre ainsi qu'aux
ministres de l'intérieur de l'époque
d'ailleurs ensemble dans ce livre blanc
que j'ai lu que j'ai lu c'est vrai que
il faut au moins un ou deux week-ends
pour le pour la vallée c'est vrai que
sincèrement et j'ai repris le rapport du
sénat on voit que tout ce qui a été
constaté sur le terrain par cette
enquête se retrouve dans le livre blanc
mais ma question est très clair comment
envisagez-vous un le recrutement de le
paiement des policiers municipaux et
surtout les tâches qui leur seront
dévolues
merci monsieur messier directeur général
vous avez la parole est ensuite
j'aimerais parole à trois autres
collègues
merci monsieur le président donc en
réponse à ces erreurs daubresse ça
rejoint peu la question que pose et
monsieur sénateur leroy savoir de la
manière dont on aborde
l'attribution de nouvelles compétences
aux polices municipales le pire serait
d'imaginer ou de mettre en oeuvre un
transfert de charges qu'on considérerait
indues pour la police et la gendarmerie
à destination des polices municipales
avec bien sûr leurs proches qui nous
serait fait légitimement de dire voilà
le une fois de plus l'état se décharge
de ses responsabilités sur les
collectivités pour ne garder que ce qui
l'intéresse avec parfois la remarque
aussi de ce que l'état se décharge sans
donner les ressources pour y faire face
pour avoir été préfet ces reproches que
j'ai entendu souvent à nous dans notre
esprit ce n'est absolument pas
l'objectif que nous nous fixons et comme
vous l'avez compris dans mon propos
introductif c'est vraiment d'arriver à
trouver un équilibre entre ce qui
revient des fonctions régaliennes des
services en charge de de la sécurité
publique et de ce qui peut relever d'une
présence de proximité comme celle que
nous constatons de plus en plus de la
part des polices municipales
aujourd'hui là où elles sont installées
que tout le monde remarquez quand les
maires ont fait le choix de développer
une vraie police municipale je parle pas
de quelques agents qui assurent la
police du stationnement et c'est pas
plusieurs actifs dans mon propos mais on
voit bien qu'il ya deux façons d'aborder
le rôle et les missions des polices
municipales selon la conception qu'on a
qu'on a le maire là où les polices
municipales sont en place et se
développe
on peut constater des policiers
municipaux bien sélectionner formés et
dotés d'un matériel tout à fait
performante qui est en général
s'accompagne aussi d'un réseau de
vidéoprotection pour les villes
concernées à la hauteur de des objectifs
qui sont qui sont poursuivis donc il est
important de concevoir ses nouvelles
responsabilités confiées aux polices
municipales comme étant un des éléments
du continuum de sécurité et pas de
transfert de charges entre la police la
gendarmerie et les polices municipales
je rejoins la remarque sous forme de
prémonition de monsieur le sénateur de
bresse ce le fait que le maire ne doit
pas être sous l'autorité du procureur de
la république
il doit pouvoir de mon point de vue
garder toute l'autorité nécessaire
vis-à-vis de sa police municipale
même si dans la mise en oeuvre des
règles
évidemment le fait de les transgresser
pourrait toujours faire courir le risque
de s'exposer à des des reproches ou à
des poursuites de la part du procureur
de la république
c'est la raison pour laquelle je ne suis
pas favorable à ce que des pouvoirs
d'investigation soient confiées aux
polices municipales ont soit bien un
registre de constatations et les polices
municipales sont sur le terrain souvent
on fait le reproche est sûr de me dire
on voit plus les policiers municipaux
que les policiers nationaux
je ne suis pas toujours d'accord vous
imaginez quand en tant que directeur
général je ne peux pas totalement
accepter cette remarque même si elle est
parfois faite à raison mais donc cette
présence de la police municipale sur le
terrain doit se traduire par une
multiplication des constatations de
procès verbaux qui permettent ensuite
aux services en charge des
investigations de procéder à ces
investigations
mais le ci ont confié des compétences
d'investigation apprécié missy pâle on
arriverait très vite à des conflits de
compétence entre gendarmerie police
nationale et
police municipale est sans doute que
quelques uns seraient tentés de vouloir
encore renforcer ses pouvoirs
d'investigation donc voilà c'est ma
façon d'aborder de manière générale
l'organisation et la répartition des
rôles entre polices municipales et les
forces de sécurité intérieures vous avez
évoqué ce ministre la question de la
formation des agents de la police
municipale
j'avoue ne pas avoir suffisamment de
recul pour me permettre de d'apprécier
cette ce niveau de formation ce que je
constate c'est que la police nationale
contribue à former les formateurs en
charge de cette formation des policiers
municipaux notamment pour tout ce qui
touche à l'armement au tir et à la
cynotechnie c'est à dire les brigades
canines
je suis bien sûr tout à fait disposé à
ce que la police nationale renforce
encore et mettre à disposition ses
capacités de formation à destination des
polices municipales
même si comme vous l'avez observé
monsieur le sénateur leroy nous avons
quand même en interne un sujet de
formation continue mais j'y reviendrai
un peu plus tard en répondant à votre
votre question pour ce qui est de
l'article 24 le directeur général de la
police et les policiers sont pas chargés
de faire la loi de l'interpréter ou de
la commenter
surtout quand elle est dans une
situation où rien n'est encore défini
complètement donc vous comprendrez que
mon propos là-dessus puisse être mesurée
et comme vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
président surtout nourri de ce que nous
constatons sur le terrain des attentes
exprimées par les policiers face à
certaines situations un peu nouvelle
renforcée par le développement de
l'internet est un usage parfois des
réseaux sociaux qui n'est pas toujours
se trouve conforme à l'esprit de nos
démocraties donc qu'elle doit être une
future monsieur le sénateur quel doit
être le support législatif
ce n'est pas à moi d'en d'en juger
ce que j'observe c'est que aujourd'hui
on est face à un développement des
prises à partie deux fonctionnaires de
police qui sont filmés ou photographiés
dans le cadre de leur activité
professionnelle et dont les photos sont
parfois diffusée à dessein sur les
réseaux sociaux pour tenter de les
identifier ou pour les menacer ou pour
tenter de récupérer des données qui
permettraient de éventuellement de s'en
prendre à eux ou développer des discours
de rennes et d'agressivité à leur égard
j'ai difficile je peux pas le diffuser
mais j'ai fait un petit extraction de
documents qui circulent sur internet à
votre disposition de ce président qui
montre des photos de gros plans de
policiers ou de gendarmes d'ailleurs
identifié à l'occasion de dispositifs
sur la voie publique avec des appels à
l'identification de ces policiers sur
des sites dont on peut penser qu'ils
n'ont pas une affection particulière
pour la police et pour la gendarmerie
donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on ait les
moyens juridiques de faire condamner les
auteurs
de ces faits ça me paraît tout à fait
indispensable et là on n'est pas au
niveau de la tension on est d'un niveau
de la réalisation
c'est à dire qu'on est vraiment je pense
on est en capacité devant un tribunal de
faire la démonstration que ce qui est
produit sur ses sites sur internet et
bien dans la volonté de nuire et de
nuire en particulier à ces personnes qui
sont photographiés en uniforme de police
ou de gendarmerie
je crois qu'on a besoin de cette
sanction juridique forte qu'elle qu'en
soit le moyen je pense que les
changements indique aujourd'hui
disponibles ne couvre peut-être pas
parfaitement toutes les opportunités on
se saisissent ces individus sur internet
et qu'il nous faut absolument avoir ce
support juridique qui nous conduisent
pas à condamner l'intention mais bien
l'acte délibéré de chercher à nuire à
ces personnes je pense aussi que dans
cette situation extrêmement compliquée
même si juridiquement ça n'est peut-être
pas parfait peut-être que les
spécialistes du droit pénal se livreront
plus tard dans des revues spécialisées à
une exégèse des textes mais je crois
aussi que les policiers et les gendarmes
ne peut pas forcément parler au nom des
gens non mais on parlait souvent avec le
directeur général gendarmerie ils ont
besoin de sentir que tous les moyens
juridiques possibles sont aujourd'hui
disponibles pour faire en sorte que
celles et ceux qui se livrent à ce type
d'action soient punis et sanctionnés moi
ce que je pouvais dire monsieur le
sénateur hervé sur aux actionnaires
s'étaient passés le monsieur ministre
c'est vous qui évoqué le sujet de
l'article 24 par le sénateur hervé vous
avez parlé donc de des drones de
l'utilisation qui en est faite et du
régime juridique qui l'accompagnent nous
sommes très demandeurs d'avoir un régime
juridique stabiliser pour l' usage de la
captation d'image au moyen d'un aéronef
puisque vous avez évoqué l'aspect
hélicoptère qui rejoint quand même
beaucoup effectivement
captation d'image qui peut être fait en
employant des drones nous avons besoin
d'avoir un régime juridique consolidé
celui auquel nous avons recours n'est
pas stabilisé et on l'a bien vu avec la
décision du conseil d'état relatives à
l'état d'urgence sanitaire qui a fait
que nous avons dû mettre fin à
l'utilisation des drones au moment de
delà de la crise de la crise sanitaire
on n'a pas d'exemple chiffrer
aujourd'hui ce que je peux vous dire sur
les chiffres c'est que dans la police
nationale nous avons aujourd'hui toutes
directions confondues 188 équipements de
type drones qui sont disponibles dans
différentes unités selon l'emploi qui en
effet il ya des unités d'intervention
comme le raid qui revoit un drone en
reconnaissance du théâtre d'opérations
dans lequel ils vont intervenir il ya
des services de surveillance aux
frontières comme la police aux
frontières qui utilisent les drones sur
dans le pas de calais par exemple pour
assurer la surveillance des plages et
éviter que des migrants s'embarque sur
des radeaux de fortune et s'exposent à
des risques et migrent vers le royaume
uni sur des distances qui sont quand
même assez importante ne pourrait pas
imaginer que on puisse mobiliser des
effectifs uniquement pour assurer cette
surveillance également à la frontière
franco italienne ou
les étrangers en situation irrégulière
qui cherchent à pénétrer sur le
territoire emprunte parfois la ligne 28
mentaux mais aussi utilisent beaucoup de
sentiers ou de chemin dans l'arrière
pays il est très difficile de détecter
notamment pendant la nuit et donc là la
paf développe aussi ce type d'activité
la police judiciaire qui s'en sert aussi
dans la préparation de ses opérations
dans des interventions qui ou dans des
surveillances qui ne permettent pas une
approche humaine en proximité
je pense parfois par exemple un des
camps occupés par la communauté des gens
du voyage qui se spécialise dans la tacc
de de fret ou ou tout autre type de
délinquance et enfin nous avons une
utilisation très maîtrisée et très
modérée par la sécurité publique dans
les situations où des manifestations de
voie publique dégénère et qu'il nous est
absolument nécessaire de pouvoir
identifier la manière dont les forces
employés vont être dirigés vers tel ou
tel endroit parce que des casseurs sont
en action est à la fois il faut pouvoir
piloter l'action des forces de l'ordre
mais aussi être en capacité si c'est
possible d'identifier et de localiser
ceux qui se livrent à des actes de
violence ou de destruction pour nourrir
les procédures judiciaires qui ne manque
pas d'être conduite à la suite de ces
exactions
donc je vous confirme ce sénateur que le
régime juridique pour encadrer tout ça
et préserver la vie privée est
légitimement la vie privée c'est à dire
que on ne puisse pas filmer les entrées
d'immeubles des terrasses d'immeubles
avec des dispositifs de floutage qui
sont parfois extrêmement difficile à
mettre en oeuvre et qui rendent
finalement l'exploitation opérationnelle
des images qui sont envoyées tout à fait
difficile à comprendre
[Musique]
et enfin vous me posez une question sur
les caméras embarquées il n'y a pas de
système de canberra embarquer pour le
moment pour les véhicules de police
quand ça c'est c'est du bricolage un
terme si vous me permettez cette
expression et je n'ai pas autorisé ce
n'est pas encadré mais on voit bien que
nous avons deux affaires phase de plus
en plus à des refus d'obtempérer
d'individus qui cherchent à échapper à
la police
et donc il est souvent très difficile à
la fois d'assurer la la conduite en
toute sécurité de pouvoir à noter tous
les éléments qui peuvent être utiles en
suite aux investigations et aussi
permettre en cas d'accident ou de
comment dire de mise en cause de la
police qu'on soit en capacité de au
travers des images d'établir que la
police à respecter parfaitement les
règles dans le cadre de son intervention
est donc comme pour les caméras piétons
les caméras embarquées la police qui est
très favorable et très favorable à cette
généralisation et rassemble usage de
plus large possible
on n'a pas peur de montrer ce qu'on fait
plus on le montre un plus on pourra
justifier du bon accomplissement de nos
missions mieux ce sera pour tout le
monde je pense
monsieur le sénateur leroy
on a déjà eu l'occasion de l'évoquer
tous ces sujets en parlant du budget de
l'âme de la police nationale et je
connais votre intérêt pour les questions
de formation dans la police nationale
vous poser la question et j'avais
presque la réponse pendant que vous la
poser puisque le mil son intérieur là la
pause est lui-même à peu près en ces
termes
hier soir en disant est ce bien la faute
des policiers
c'est effectivement d'abord la
responsabilité du directeur général sans
doute des ministres puisque le matériel
a exprimé comme ça de cette façon
hier soir mais chaque fois d'ailleurs je
voulais faire une trentaine chaque fois
que un policier blessé grièvement pas
grièvement d'ailleurs ou tuer ou que des
événements comme ceux qui se sont
produits la semaine dernière arrive pour
moins opaque directeur général c'est un
sentiment d'échec c'est à dire que ma
responsabilité c'est de faire en sorte
que toutes les opérations de police se
passe bien vous les policiers de ce pays
rentrent chez eux en bonne santé à
l'issue de leur temps de travail en
bonne santé physique et sécuriser de
manière juridique pour ça ils ont besoin
d'être sélectionné ils ont besoin d'être
formés de manière suffisante au niveau
initial est de continuer à être formés
tout au long de leur vie professionnelle
on peut avoir des débats sur la manière
dont la formation initiale et organisé
vous savez que elle se déroulait sur une
formation initiale des gardiens de la
paix ces deux ans au départ il y avait
douze mois de formation théorique 12
mois de stage et depuis cette année donc
les garennes la paix ne s'usent plus que
huit mois de formation théorique et 16
mois de stage
il ya des débats qui existe entre
spécialistes de la formation pour dire
ce que la durée de la formation est un
préalable essentiel incontournable à la
qualité de la formation
je n'ai pas d'idée arrêtée sur le sujet
ce que je constate c'est qu'aujourd'hui
on a quand même énormément de moyens à
notre disposition pour faire autrement
que de former les gens en présentiel
il ya des techniques d'intervention dans
la police ne pouvait pas faire autrement
que de les apprendre sur un tatami ou
dans un espace sportif le tir ça ne
s'apprend camp que dans un stand de tir
quoique on voit qu'aujourd'hui la
réalité virtuelle et augmentée nous
permet de faire beaucoup de choses de
manières de manière simuler et donc la
crise sanitaire nous a quand même fait
la démonstration que on pouvait sans
doute délivrer un maximum
d'enseignements à distance vous pouvez
aussi sans doute beaucoup plus
travailler à distance
le ministère de l'intérieur et la police
nationale d'ailleurs ont fait
l'expérience de ces nouveaux modes de
fonctionnement et on a pu constater
peut-être le retard que nous avions à
rattraper en la matière donc est ce que
c'est un problème de temps de formation
je pense que c'est d'abord un sujet de
contenus de formation et de qualité de
formation pour ça il faut des formateurs
il faut les recruter les former et qu'il
soit disponible comme je l'aï dit tout
le temps de la vie professionnelle
et c'est là sans doute que la police
nationale a une marge de progression
très importante à faire d'abord parce
que naturellement je pense qu'on n'est
pas forcément toujours enclin à
s'astreindre aux heures de formation
continue
on le fait pour tout ce qui touche à
l'utilisation des armes et sans doute
pas assez puisque il y a à peu près 65 %
de policiers qui font leurs trois tirs
alimentaire dans l'année
quand on a un incident de tir dans la
police l'igpn si j'ai peine et saisi la
première chose qu'on regarde c'est de
savoir si vous avez fait vos trois tirs
réglementaires dans l'année donc c'est
quelque chose d'assez important mais
pour tout ce qui touche aux neuf heures
de formation continue qui peuvent avoir
trait aux gestes techniques
d'intervention à la déontologie et à
d'autres domaines on est sur des
proportions qui sont très faibles et qui
mérite d'être sans doute réévalué et je
sais que le ministre de l'intérieur il y
est très attentif et va sans doute faire
des annonces en ce sens dans les jours
qui viennent
ce qu'il faut aussi dire à la décharge
de tout le monde sait que depuis 2015 on
a vécu quand même des années assez
extraordinaire au mauvais sens du terme
avec d'abord les attaques et les
attentats pardon de 2015 2016 et tout ce
que ça a pu produire comme effet
secondaire dans l'engagement des forces
de l'ordre on a eu ensuite cette
séquence du dg les jeunes qui a
énormément mobiliser les forces de
l'ordre sur des actions de maintien de
l'ordre comme vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le sénateur avec parfois des
effectifs qui étaient employées qui
n'étaient pas tous formés un aux
techniques du maintien d'ordre est donc
la formation continue on a sans doute
fait les frais et on ne peut pas être
exigeant vis-à-vis des policiers sont
nous-mêmes respecter nos engagements en
termes de formation de formation
continue et nous allons nous y attacher
dans les dents les jours et dans les
semaines qui viennent je crois le social
coeur avoir évolué à la question
auparavant pour ce qui était des tâches
indues et du transfert des charges entre
la police nationale et la police
municipale et avoir également répondu à
vos questions sur le recrutement
merci monsieur l'acteur verger de série
de questions d'abord de monsieur jérôme
durain et de monsieur jean-yves locon
ensuite marie pierre de la gontrie jette
ali mohamed swahili et monsieur alain
marc
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
directeur général merci de votre
présence
la confiance des français visait la
police a baissé de 8 points selon le
baromètre annuel du cevipof ça reste une
institution très apprécié des français
un peu moins qu'à l'étranger
c'était à 80% après les attentats est ce
que le sujet central dans la période
est ce que ce n'est pas quand même un
sujet de réconciliation entre la police
et les citoyens j'ai entendu les mots
vous et prononcer la foi et la confiance
que vous affirmiez envers les valeurs de
cette institution mais vous êtes ici au
milieu des luttes politiques qui savent
bien que la vertu du plus grand nombre
n'efface pas les égarements de
quelques-uns on a payé pour savoir
donc est-ce que ce sujet n'est pas aussi
important au niveau de l'institution
elle même que de chaque policier sur le
terrain sk pas des sujets de
coordination de commandement de
transparence de contrôle je pense aux
images on parle beaucoup des images en
ce moment l'effectivité du droit d'accès
aux images pour les citoyens vient
d'être on a bien démontré qu'elles
avaient été défaillants dans une affaire
qui est sorti récemment
est-ce qu'il ya pas un régime unique qui
nous permettrait d'avoir une réponse à
la fois pour protéger les policiers
et puis pour faire baisser la pression
et les citoyens oui merci monsieur le
directeur général alors tout à l'heure
vous avez montré ses photos de policiers
qu'on cherche à identifier la démarche
malheureusement nous en avons aussi vu
les conséquences sur professeur samuel
pâtit c'est un problème général des
réseaux sociaux
donc ce que c'est légitime de faire
quelque chose de spécifique pour la
fonction pour les policiers alors que ça
devrait être finalement quelque chose à
la fois d'équilibré mais qui répondent
aux problèmes globale de l'évolution de
la société et des réseaux sociaux
pourraient souscrire à votre conclusion
mais les images de terribles j'aimerais
souscrivent à votre couple ou des images
terribles que nous avons vue ces
dernières semaines
pauvre pour beaucoup de français un un
problème de confiance qui s'interroge
sur
la formation notre collègue l'a évoqué
sur le management technique et politique
de la police est donc question est ce
qu'il ya des choses que qui doit être
changé de ce point de vue là à votre
niveau et au niveau politique
enfin les syndicats de police souvent
nous nous indique que la pression qui
leur est mise sur la politique du
chiffre les empêche d'aborder finalement
dans de manière sereine leurs relations
avec la population est ce qu'il n'ya pas
quelque chose à revoir
de ce point de vue là enfin concernant
la préfecture de police de paris en
particulier ce que vous considérez que
il ya des évolutions à faire pour
harmoniser sur l'ensemble du territoire
le fonctionnement et le management de la
police merci monsieur le quand madame
marie pierre de la gontrie
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
directeur général vous êtes aujourd'hui
devant la commission des lois du sénat
24 heures après l'audition très longue
du ministre de l'intérieur par la
commission des lois de l'assemblée et
donc cet agenda est très utile puisqu'il
nous permet de revenir sur des
propositions qui ont été faites hier par
le ministre sur lequel vous pourriez
nous apportez donc des précisions en
tant que directeur opérationnel de ces
sujets le ministre de l'intérieur a
voulu d'une formule lister les sept
péchés capitaux à l'origine je prends
ces termes de problèmes structurels donc
c'était un premier une première avancée
la reconnaissance de problèmes
structurels
premier point l'erreur fondamentale le
peu de formation à quoi sert la
formation initiale n'était pas une bonne
mesure
comment entendez-vous donc répondre sur
ce point le sujet de la formation été
évoquée néanmoins pourriez vous nous
donner des précisions en tant que
directeur général
deuxième point il a indiqué qu'il n'y
avait pas assez de chefs présents dans
la rue et qu'il faudrait
un corps d'intermédiaires d'encadrement
plus nombreux sur le terrain là aussi
comment entendez vous mettre en oeuvre
cette demande
troisième point il a annoncé la
généralisation des caméras piétons au
1er juillet 2021 nous savons que ces
caméras piétons sont déficientes dans la
mesure où elles ont eu une autonomie
très faible qui ne permet pas que le le
policier la mettre en oeuvre lorsqu'il
prend son service et l'arrêtent
lorsqu'il termine c'est d'ailleurs une
demande du syndicat des commissaires est
ce que vous pensez donc cette
généralisation possible au 1er juillet
2021 dans des conditions correctes
le deuxième sujet c'est votre
affirmation selon lequel et c'est celle
du ministre l'intérieur également il n'y
aurait pas de divorce entre la police et
la population alors sur mesure et un
tout à l'heure à rappeler les opinions
favorables
il faut indiquer que si elles étaient
80% après les attentats 2015
elle est suite elle a chuté à 66 %
désormais et il faut s'intéresser à ce
qui se passe au niveau de l'igpn
je ne veux pas vous demander de prendre
position sur le sort de l'igpn néanmoins
les policiers c'est 7% des effectifs de
la fonction publique
55% des sanctions prononcées dans la
fonction publique concerne des policiers
on a vu un accroissement de 23% des
enquêtes judiciaire confiée à l'igpn en
2019 on a vu que 50 % l'été pour
violences donc on ne peut évidemment pas
considérer qu'il n'y a pas de sujet sur
ce point enfin concernant magnanville
j'encourage chacun à la plus grande
prudence le ministre lui-même le 2
novembre devant la commission des lois
du sénat reconnaissait je cite on ne
sait pas si ce sont les images sur les
réseaux sociaux qui ont fait naître cet
attentat donc dans un moment où on a
tendance à prendre des exemples pour
illustrer les défauts de tel ou tel
process je pense qu'il est important de
d'être très précis c'est pour ça je me
permettais de données cette précision
merci madame monsieur thani mohamed
soilihi
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
directeur général tout à l'heure vous
avez évoqué les trois territoires
ultramarins qui font l'expérimentation
du tpn directeur territorial de la
police nationale qui fait que la paf et
la police nationale voit se voir réunis
à la tête desquels un seul un seul chef
vous avez dit que les premiers résultats
étaient encourageants
et effectivement la commission des lois
du sénat s'est déplacé l'année dernière
en guyane puisque la guyane la nouvelle
calédonie et mayotte sont concernés et
la bave aux collègues et
l'administration préfectorale nous ont
effectivement affirmé qu'il y avait des
premiers résultats encourageants
moi je pense qu'il faudrait davantage de
temps pour porter un jugement parce que
la réforme à -1 d'hénin d'existence dans
dans l'est certains territoires et sans
que cela ait un lien
je voulais vous parler de la
recrudescence sans précédent de la
violence dans mon département mayotte
dont une immense majorité et commises
par des bandes de jeunes est ce que le
veau des peines mais ce qu'aviez vous a
fait remonter cette recrudescence en
violant sans précédent pardon et à votre
avis à quoi est elle due et quelles
seraient les solutions pour y remédier
je sais que localement vos collègues
revendiquent par exemple un deuxième
commissariat puisque ces violences sont
essentiellement urbaine et chose
étonnante la deuxième ville de mayotte
kong ou qui a plus de trente mille
habitants n'a pas de commissariat par
exemple donc ça fait partie des
solutions qui sont préconisées sur place
est ce que pour vous il faudrait aller
vers cette direction
merci merci monsieur alain marc
merci président monsieur le directeur
général
ma première observation rejoint un petit
plus de celle de madame de la gontrie
concernant les caméras piétons je veux
juste rappeler que mon collègue jean
pierre decool quand il était député
nous étions d'ailleurs tous les deux
députés ainsi jean à côté de l'autre
à l'époque a fait passer une ppl sur les
caméras piétons adopté à l'unanimité
à l'époque à l'assemblée nationale il
devenu sénateur et ici nous avons tous
adoptés et chers collègues vous savez
quand est ce qu elle était adoptée un
autre 2018
promulguée promulguée ou 2018 depuis
août 2010 8 entre temps on a eu quand
même les gilets jaunes m donc il me
semble que l'exécutif aurait pu tenir
compte de cet état de fait surtout quand
on regarde d'autres pays où cela existe
et où cela marche très bien alors je
voudrais savoir monsieur directeur
général si vous êtes très contente du
matériel que vous avez et si la réponse
de l'exécutif en la matière est de
nature à satisfaire à la fois la
représentation nationale et les français
parce que je ne crois pas que sur tout à
fait le cas même si le ministre darmanin
hier a bien dit que ce serait
une commande de général je crois pour le
mois de juin ou de juillet deuxièmement
j'ai pas tout à fait la même lecture
quand j'entends les gens à côté de moi
quand il voit les images des
manifestations
du moins pas tout à fait la même que
celle de mes collègues de gauche
quand on voit des gentils armés de
barres de fer s'approcher des policiers
je peux vous dire une chose c'est que la
plupart des gens prennent fait et cause
plutôt pour les policiers et la réponse
à cela ce sont des gens malheureusement
qui sont après moi j'aimerais savoir si
nos policiers jeu directeur général ont
les moyens d'avoir une réponse
appropriée
je ne vous dis pas ce que pensent
beaucoup de gens ceux qui souhaiterait
mais je crois que ce ne sont pas
forcément les réponses médiatique que
nous avons aujourd'hui qui sont celles
de nos concitoyennes donc je voulais
vous dire d'abord tout le soutien que
nous vous apportons les uns et les
autres et vous dire que j'aimerais
savoir quels sont les moyens dont vous
disposez dans ces cas là merci monsieur
madame boyer puis monsieur bah merci
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues monsieur le directeur général
permettez-moi d'abord de vous exprimer
toute ma gratitude au moment où on veut
nous imposer un débat que je trouve
absolument pestilentielle sur les
soi-disant violences policières
même si peut-être certaines
retranscription de d'événements au film
et peuvent nous laisser penser qu' il y
a des difficultés
je voudrais simplement offert une petite
remarque à une actrice qui s'appelle
alexandra lamy qui a mis sur des réseaux
sociaux un message de soutien et elle a
été prise à partie et critiquer de façon
très violente vis-à-vis de tous ceux qui
viennent casser du flic pour employer
cette expression abominable qui pourtant
circulent mais c'est vrai que des
pompiers agressés par les victimes qui
est bien le secourir des policiers
frappaient à coups de pied en pleine
mâchoire par un patient hospitalisé des
gendarmes callas etc
voilà la réalité malheureusement les
guets-apens c'est malheureusement d une
réalité quotidienne vous le soulignez en
2019 les forces de l'ordre étaient
chaque jour la cible
en moyenne deux paraît-il 110 agression
et comme beaucoup de français comme
beaucoup de mes collègues je voudrais
dire combien je suis scandalisé par la
répétition de ces actes parce que comme
ici je pense que nous sommes tous
convaincus qu'il n'ya pas de liberté
sans ordre il n'y a pas d'ordre sans
respect de nos valeurs et de nos règles
mais malheureusement les chiffres de la
violence monte et elle est partout et
c'est pour ça que je vous réitère ma
gratitude
j'ai pas faire une liste et que ceci
parce que je crois que nos mémoires sont
suffisamment imprégnés des tragédies que
nous devons que nous avons dû affronter
ces dernières années que malheureusement
nous affronterons encore je pense
notamment aux trop nombreuses attaques
de terroristes islamistes
mais si la france reste debout si notre
démocratie fonctionne si on peut vaquer
à nos occupations c'est grâce aux forces
de l'ordre
et c'est grâce à ces hommes et ces
femmes qui risquent leur vie pour celle
des autres et je crois qu'on mesure pas
assez le prix payé par vous tous par
tous les acteurs de la sécurité lorsque
vous remplissez vos missions et par vaux
famille également
parce que ça aussi c'est une réalité qui
est souvent ignorée et il ya aussi cette
expression qui est particulièrement
libre dans les médias des deux personnes
qui vont contre la police ces
manifestations où on scande tout le
monde déteste la police et qu'on a
laissé prospérer
ça aussi je pense que ça participe à un
climat qui est particulièrement délétère
pour notre cohésion sociale et je
voudrais revenir sur un seul point celui
où on entend souvent en plus les
manifestations criaient ces mots atroce
suicidez vous ce qui me semble vraiment
abjecte
selon les chiffres fournis par la police
nationale 59 policiers se sont suicidés
en 2019 soit 160 % de plus qu'en 2010 8
en juin 2018 le rapport de la commission
d'enquêté sénatoriale sur l'état des
forces de sécurité intérieure alerte est
déjà sur le taux de suicide anormalement
élevées au sein des forces de l'ordre
et alors que les menaces les
intimidations et les agressions contre
des policiers sont en constante
augmentation
il est indispensable de renforcer le
dispositif de prévention contre les
suicides au sein de la police la cellule
d écoute
mise en place en 1996 semble inadapté
face à la réalité du terrain
celle ci n'aurait reçu qu environ 300
appels
entre le 28 septembre et le 31 décembre
2019 contre 6000 sollicitations pour la
plateforme alternative géré par
l'association sos policiers en détresse
moi je voudrais avoir votre avis
monsieur le directeur sur cette question
et je vous remercie pour tous et pour
cette réponse merci beaucoup merci
monsieur bah c'est le directeur général
il ya quelques mois nous vous avons
auditionné sur des questions connexes à
celle que nous traitons aujourd'hui une
observation d'abord rien n'est plus
facile que de montrer les forces de
l'ordre en action pour une bonne et
simple raison c'est que c'est leur
métier de recourir à la contrainte est
long nous mêmes le monopole légal
il faut bien entendu vous avez parlé
notamment de formation que dans cette
action extrêmement délicate et avec
toute l'émotion que peut susciter chez
les policiers comme chez les gendarmes
mobiles d'ailleurs des agressions dont
ils peuvent être victimes et ce contexte
aussi de terrorisme de menaces et de
violence ambiante
il respecte les méthodes des techniques
d'intervention qui leur sont enseignées
que l'encadrement soit suffisant pour
qu' il n'y ait pas de débordements vous
avez proposé au mois de juin dernier qui
ne soit plus recouru désormais parmi les
techniques d'interpellation à la
technique dite de la clé d'étranglement
un groupe de travail a été mis en place
je me souviens vous avoir interrogé à
l'époque en disant mais qu'est ce qu'on
va faire si on n'utilise plus la clé
d'étranglement pour maîtriser des
individus qui sont réfractaires et
qu'ils ne puissent pas simplement l
instruction verbale qui va leur être
données qui cherchent à s'échapper
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir
faire pour maîtriser ces individus si on
n'utilise plus la clé d'étranglement or
le groupe de travail devait remettre ses
conclusions le 1er septembre je n'ai pas
connaissance
que des propositions et été arrêté ni
que des décisions étaient prises et je
voudrais bien savoir où vous en êtes sur
ce dossier très délicat parce que j'ai
eu le sentiment pour vous dire la vérité
que la réponse qui a été vue qui a été
fait à l'époque était une réponse qui
tenait à la pression de l'actualité et
que finalement on se retrouve bien
embarrassé de trouver des solutions qui
permettent à la police d'être efficace
tout en évitant de procéder à des gestes
qui pourraient éventuellement avoir des
conséquences néfastes pour l'individu
qu'on cherche à maîtriser
merci et enfin madame gatel etc si
monsieur le président monsieur le
directeur général je tiens à vous
assurer comme beaucoup de mes collègues
vous et tous les policiers qui
travaillent aujourd'hui dans des
conditions extrêmement difficiles de
tout mon soutien même si naturellement
des actions un peu particulière et on va
dire difficilement acceptable dans notre
pays peuvent poser question la sécurité
je crois que c'est la protection des
plus fragiles et des plus hauts depuis
le mouvement des gilets jaunes depuis
une série de manifestations assez
violente moi je l' ai vu dans mon
département avec les opérations de notre
dame des landes on voir régulièrement
d autres enfin des attitudes très
violente qui sont le fait d'un certain
nombre d'individus qui régulièrement
font dégénérer les manifestations parce
qu'ils poursuivent d'autres objectifs
que celui des femmes des libertés est
très souvent les gens disent mais
comment se fait-il qu'il y ait toujours
un noyau dur dans des manifestations
c'est un noyau dur qui souvent le même
comment la police n'arrive-t-elle pas à
prévenir les débordements qui
interviennent toujours à la fin des
manifestations
quels sont les moyens que vous avez de
mieux identifier ces gens qui sont des
experts dans leur dans leurs gestes et
leurs attitudes
comment peut-on ainsi sécuriser des
manifestations je vous remercie
merci madame eh bien monsieur de la
tonhalle vous avez la parole pour cette
série de questions merci monsieur le
président saleh certaines des réponses
coûteront sans doute des questions
posées par plusieurs parlementaires mais
je suis reviendrait donc la question de
ce secteur que vous avez posées à propos
de la confiance des français est une
question qui est revenue de la part de
membres de vos collègues
on la sent bien cette question présente
dans les médias aussi passablement parmi
les élus de notre de notre pays
moi je suis je ne rejoindrai pas votre
expression qui consisterait à dire qu'on
a besoin de réconcilier les français je
crois que tout le monde fait le constat
que malgré les difficultés auxquelles
nous sommes confrontés il ya un
sentiment positif qui s'exprime à
l'égard de la police qui est très
largement majoritaire qui n'est certes
pas au niveau de celui qu'on a pu
connaître en 2015 à l'époque des
attentats mais qui reste très largement
positif et souvent j'en parle avec les
personnels que je rencontre notamment
dans les territoires les plus exposés à
la délinquance et aux violences où ils
s'interrogent parfois sur le sens de
leur mission sur l'utilité de ce qu'ils
font ils m'interpellent à juste titre et
sur le sentiment qu'ils peuvent
concevoir d'une rupture assez fortes ont
une partie de la population est
finalement pas seulement la police mais
celles et ceux qui veulent vivre en paix
dans notre belle démocratie
donc je pense qu'il ya une partie de la
population qui est irréconciliable avec
la police une partie de la population
qui a fait le choix de vivre en marge de
vivre dans la délinquance décidé
d'exploiter toutes les failles possibles
pour faire du trafic de stupéfiants
volley essayer de se soustraire à toutes
les règles que nous avons pour bien
vivre ensemble
donc cela je pense qu'on va je n'ai pas
l'ambition de tenter de les reconquérir
après on a quand même globalement
certains d'entre vous l'ont dit une
écrasante majorité de françaises et de
français qui sont d'abord soucieux de
leur sécurité qui sont parfois
questionné par ce qu'ils voient à la
télévision la télévision en lisant les
journaux mais qui soutiennent je pense
toujours la police dans son action et
nous nous livrons assez régulièrement à
des enquêtes de satisfaction qui sont
conduites par ipsos donc un organisme
indépendant dont tout le monde connaît
le sérieux et qu'ils étudiaient un petit
peu et qui essaient de nous éclairer au
delà même des grandes tendances ou des
propos qui peuvent être tenus sur le
rapport qu'entretiennent les français
avec la police il ya une chose
importante qui se dégage c'est que le
sentiment de confiance à l'égard de la
police est d'autant plus fort qu'on a
été usé du service public de la police
quand vous demandez à des françaises et
des français qui ont besoin de faire
appel à la police
ils se disent c'est super ça marche j'ai
des chiffres mais on frôle les 90 %
ce par contre qui qui la critiquent ou
qui s'en plaignent c'est ce finalement
qui se tiennent toujours à l'écart de la
delà de la police nationale mais si on
considère les évolutions telles que vous
ne le décrivez par exemple sous le même
sondage même sondage même société qui le
fait en 2017
est ce que vous considérez que la police
travaille bien 86 % en 2010 9 81% donc
c'est quand même enfin sondage interne
qu'on ne partage pas avec l'extérieur
mais qui moi me laisse confiant sur
l'état de notre relation entre la police
et la population et moi qui suis
originaire de la province
quand je parle avec alors évidemment ils
savent ce que je fais mais bon quand on
se connaît on se parle aussi plus libre
je pense que le lien tels que parfois on
leur présente n'est pas forcément celui
qu'on retrouve dans la rue dans les
grandes manifestations ou parfois
exprimées dans les médias pour autant
est-ce qu'on doit s'en satisfaire
je ne crois pas on est aussi lucide sur
l'état de des rapports entre la société
et les institutions parce que la police
est certes sans doute le réceptacle de
toutes les critiques et de toutes les
violences mais aujourd'hui bien d'autres
institutions de notre pays le sont
également
vous êtes vous dire à vous élus de
terrain à quel point les élus l'autorité
des élus et est contestée gelé vécu
aussi dans les départements où j'ai pu
exercer à quel point les enseignants
sont contestés à quel point le service
des urgences dans les hôpitaux sont
contestés par par des gens qui ne
supportent plus rien donc il faut sans
doute nous interroger nous police nous
le faisons nous travaillons un des
objectifs que nous avons parce que je
pense que nous sommes par exemple c'est
un point de faiblesse par rapport à la
gendarmerie a un potentiel dans la
réserve civile de 30 mille gendarmes
et nous nous avons simplement 6000
réservistes dans la police et notamment
parmi ses réservistes beaucoup d'anciens
policiers ou beaucoup d'anciens adjoints
de sécurité mais assez peu finalement de
personnes issues de la société civile
je pense que outre
l'apport le soutien que pourrait nous
apporter ses réservistes je pense qu'en
associant davantage la société civile de
notre travail à nos missions
on pourrait aussi contribuer à renforcer
ce lien policiers de police population
on a un handicap par rapport à la jambe
mais nationale c'est que les réservistes
de la gendarmerie sont armés pas ceux de
la police et donc pour leur permettre de
conduire des missions sur le terrain ce
qui fait l'intérêt de l'engagement du
réserviste en général si c'est juste
pour le mettre à côté un téléphone et
répondent au travail et terrien d'écrans
d'ordinateur en général ça ne mobilise
pas beaucoup l'intérêt pour celles et
ceux qui veut son qui veulent s'engager
il faut qu'on trouve la solution
législative pour nous permettre d'armes
et d'armer les réservistes de la police
nationale alors bien sûr il faut 2 il
faut monsieur le sénateur il faut du
contrôle il faut s'appuyer sur
l'effectivité des images moi je les dis
et je le vois avec les policiers
aujourd'hui les policiers n'ont pas peur
du recours à l'image les policiers
revendique de pouvoir aussi de ne pas
simplement subir les images de ceux qui
viennent se coller contre avec un
smartphone on le voit dans des formes de
provocation espérant qu'un policier ou
un gendarme disions que face à
l'accumulation des provocations ou des
projectiles qui sont lancés contre eux
non il faut que les gendarmes les
policiers s'équipent avec du matériel
qui fonctionne là je réponds un peu
collectivement à plusieurs sénatrices et
sénateurs qui m'ont interpellé
évidemment le matériel qui est
aujourd'hui disponible la police est
équipé de plus de 10000 10700 caméra
piétons la gendarmerie avait peut-être
senti les choses on en a acheté que
quelques dizaines d'un matériel qui
n'est pas un qui n'est pas fonctionnel
un sénateur l'a dit tout à l'heure pas
d'autonomie de la batterie difficulté à
changer la batterie difficultés à
rentrer son numéro et rio difficulté à
l'accroché de manière convenable aux
vêtements dont sont équipés les
policiers donc le président de la
république a pris un engagement il veut
trente mille caméras piéton pour les
policiers les gendarmes au 1er juillet
2021 le ministre de l'intérieur bien sûr
vous en doutez a pris exactement le même
engagement mais le mythe intérieur le
voit quotidiennement ils interrogent des
policiers quand ils rencontrent qui lui
disent ce que je vous dis c'est à dire
que c'est un matériel qui complètement
défectueux
donc quand ce matériel est défectueux
évidemment on ne s'en sert pas et on n'a
pas forcément la disponibilité des
images quand on voudrait en avoir en
avoir besoin
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle un
nouveau marché public est en cours
qu'ils puissent à la fois donner accès à
du matériel qu'ils soient performants
robuste et dans la mesure où la loi
évoluerez en capacité de nous donner
accès à d'autres fonctionnalités que
celles auxquelles nous avons accès
aujourd'hui notamment le renvoi distancé
pour nous ce qui est très important
c'est que comme des policiers sont
isolés sur le terrain qu'on ait la
capacité de faire cette transmission de
la caméra un policier en difficulté la
salle de commandement prend la main sur
la caméra et voit immédiatement ce qui
ce passe temps capacité d'envoyer
renfort de donner les bonnes instruction
donc ce sont des choses pour lesquelles
les budgets sont déjà identifiés les
marchés sont en cours et les engagements
du président de la république et de
militaires seront évidemment évidemment
tenu et ce sera un instrument important
du contrôle de l'activité des policiers
les policiers n'ont pas peur de ce
qu'ils font les policiers sont fiers de
ce qu'ils font
donc tout ça passe aussi par un accès le
plus large possible à l'image et que je
ne sais pas si on peut parler de guerre
quand des manifestants agressent des
policiers mais enfin dans les
confrontations qui nous oppose et la
confrontation de la violence physique de
la violence verbale mais il ya aussi la
confrontation des images dont on sait
aujourd'hui la place qu'elle qu'elle
peut prendre j'espère avoir répondu à
peu près à votre à votre question
donc c'est monsieur le sénateur ne
compte qu il parlait tout à l'heure de
ces images terribles et delà du problème
de confiance pour les pour l'épauler
français je croyais avoir répondu dans
ce propos et avec eux vous parlez du des
changements de management de techniques
la pression sur la politique du chiffre
qui pourrait avoir un impact négatif sur
l'attitude des policiers sur le terrain
je crois que le milieu intérieur a été
clair là dessus et je le suis d'autant
plus que je mets en oeuvre les
instructions qu'ils me donnent il n'y a
pas aujourd'hui de politique du chiffre
au ministère de l'intérieur pour la
police nationale
mais comme des ministres intérieur le
répète souvent et ce n'est pas à lui
seul qui en expriment le besoin motion
ait besoin pour s'assurer de la mise en
oeuvre des politiques publiques
déterminé par le ministre on a besoin
d'avoir de quelques références on a
besoin de savoir si le niveau de saisie
de quantités de produits stupéfiants le
là où sont arrêtés les trafiquants voilà
on a besoin de chiffres comme ça pour
avoir des politiques de sécurité
intelligente
donc on essaie de ne pas solliciter les
services parce qu'il ya toujours cette
eau si cette pression du ce qu'on
appelle le mot je n'aime pas le mot mais
je vais l'utiliser quand même dur
parking où on demande toujours plus pour
essayer d'en savoir plus pas toujours
d'ailleurs parfois on perd de vue
l'intérêt qu'il y a demandé ces
informations en tout cas on oublie de
dire d'arrêter ce n'est plus la peine on
n'a plus besoin de ces chiffres mais on
s'appuie sur les statistiques dont
dispose aujourd'hui notamment au travers
du service de statistiques du ministère
l'intérieur qui nous permet de
bénéficier d'un centre de données qui
nous aident à faire des choix de
politique publique à faire des choix
aussi d'investissement des choix
d'affectation termes de ressources
humaines
il vaut peut-être mieux mettre des
moyens là on en a besoin que là où on
arrive à faire face à la situation à
laquelle nous sommes
nous sommes confrontés donc oui notre
objectif c'est de contribuer ainsi au
sénateur à avoir une relation saine et
apaisée avec la population la sénatrice
je vais tout de suite répondre à vous
avez évoqué par rapport à la sphère de
magnanville je n'ai certainement pas
fait référence à la sphère de mes
oignons ville vous verrez dans le
verbatim de mon propos comme étant un
moyen de justifier d'avoir recours à
l'article 24 ou de de pénaliser la
diffusion de photos de policiers sur
internet
je lui ai simplement placé en référence
de ce que les policiers ont constaté
comme étant un basculement décisif dans
la manière dont on pouvait s'en prendre
à celle qu'ils ont compris et avec une
forme de stupéfaction de sidération
qu'il est je crois les touche
profondément
je suis allé dans les yvelines mais même
en circulant ailleurs sur le territoire
national ils ont été sidérés par cet
acte criminel
enfin absolu de ces de ce couple égorgé
en présence de leurs enfants
voilà on imagine toujours quand on
s'engage dans la police qui est une part
de risque
ce risque on est prêt à le prendre même
si on n'est pas payé que pour prendre
des risques mais qu'on soit en capacité
d'être pris pour cible
simplement parce qu on est policier et
d'aller jusqu'à vous chercher chez vous
je crois que ça c'est un marqueur
important dans l'état d'esprit général
des policiers et ça n'est certainement
pas un argument pour justifier le
recours à l'article 24 ou toute autre
forme de de pénalisation de la diffusion
de photos sur internet donc qui n'est
pas de malentendus dans la façon dont je
me suis exprimé tout à l'heure même la
sénatrice donc vous avez repris
quelques-uns des sept péchés capitaux du
ministre de l'intérieur
hier soir devant la commission des lois
de l'assemblée nationale
vous avez parlé
de la formation gelé indiqué tout à
l'heure on a une vraie difficulté la
police à laquelle on doit cette laisser
la question de la formation continue
donc ça ça nécessite d'avoir des
moniteurs de les recruter de les former
d'organiser et de faire en sorte que ces
heures de formation auquel les policiers
ont droit soient soit vraiment organisé
et suivies au même titre que ce qu'on
peut le faire pour le tir dans la police
nationale
vous avez dit pas assez de recherches
sur le terrain pardon oui il est repris
en chine c'était pour me poser la
question on voit l'enjeu
je passe volontiers sur la question non
mais on sait bien que l'encadrement est
une question importante pour toutes les
activités opérationnelles en
l'occurrence si on fait référence aux
événements qui se sont produits ces
derniers jours il y avait de
l'encadrement sur le terrain donc
l'encadrement on peut aussi parfois
défaillir mai
il est certain qu'on doit faire en sorte
d'organiser en toutes circonstances et
en tous lieux la présence de chefs qui
assume la responsabilité des actions qui
sont conduites qui sont conduites sur le
terrain c'est la généralisation des
caméras piétons je vous ai répondu je
crois et sur le divorce entre la police
et la population je ne pense pas devoir
revenir vous avez compris à quel point
je suis mais je ne fais pas parce que je
cherche à vous tenir un propos qui
serait un propos convenus à l'égard de
la commission des lois du sénat c'est
parce que j'en suis comme l'a rappelé un
sénateur tout à l'heure une sénatrice
est entièrement convaincu que je ne
pense que la situation n'est pas
dégradée au point tel qu'il est décrit
aujourd'hui dans certains espaces
médiatiques
vous avez posé la question de l'igpn la
gp n ayez crainte dans la police est là
elle fait la preuve
malheureusement deux parce que ça
traduit dès maintenant la preuve de fond
de son efficacité comme l'a rappelé là
aussi le miz intérieur hier soir c'est
un service qui bénéficie de la confiance
de l'autorité judiciaire pas simplement
du directeur général de la police
nationale vous savez on est dans une
maison où on souhaite être irréprochable
les infractions qui peuvent être
commises et qui peuvent parfois nous
déshonorer nous gêne énormément dans
notre action au quotidien et donc le
nôtre objectif c'est vraiment de
rappeler à chacune et à chacun dans
cette institution
quelles sont les règles d'être juste
quand on sanctionne mais d'être aussi
sévères parce que l'exigence est forte
vis-à-vis de nous on sera d'autant plus
sévère qu'on sera juste et le gpm fait
un travail remarquable dans des
conditions extrêmement difficiles et
dans tous les cas le directeur général
de la police nationale il a besoin
d'avoir à côté de lui un service
d'inspection à qui confient des enquêtes
disciplinaires qui confie des missions
d'audit
voilà je pense que si demain ça devait
être retirée au directeur général comme
on l'entend parfois dans la réflexion
qui
qui sont conduites à propos de l'igpn je
serai certainement obligé d'en recréer
une pour m'appuyer sur une capacité de
management qui me paraît tout à fait
automatique c'est quand même de faire la
police au sein de au sein de ma propre
maison et de ne pas être dépendant d'une
institution extérieur donc j'apporte mon
soutien à un gp n est vraiment quand je
vois que ce qui s'est passé
place de la république ce qui s'est
passé en 7ème arrondissement on le
ramène et on le résume à la question du
gipn j'avoue mon incompréhension quand
il ya le feu on dit pas que c'est le
problème des pompiers ont dit que c'est
le problème de bien autre chose mais ce
n'est pas un problème des pompiers
monsieur le sénateur vous avez évoqué la
question de l'outre-mer territoire sans
doute insuffisamment valorisé dans la
manière dont on parle de la police c'est
la raison pour laquelle j'ai créé auprès
de moins la fonction de chef de la
mission outre mer
parce que j'ai tellement de choses à
traiter que parfois je n'y accorde pas
toute l'attention requise et
l'éloignement crée parfois un peu de
voilà de décalage entre ce qui se fait
ce qui se fait outre mer ce qui mérite
d'être valorisé et bien sûr on doit
aussi accompagner accompagné à l'action
de nos collègues policiers sur le
terrain j'ai été souvent en relation en
visioconférence avec monsieur cavier le
directeur territorial de la police
comme vous l'avez dit parmi les sujets
auxquels les policiers sont confrontés
et la population parce que je sais aussi
que c'est le problème de la population
n'a pas peut-être d'abord le premier à
la population d'être le problème de la
police
c'est la question des mineurs isolés qui
arrivent en nombre et qui sont souvent
très fin à l'origine ni livrés à
eux-mêmes pour commettre
un maximum d'infraction pour parfois à
l'origine aussi de troubles à l'ordre
public
on voit que il y a beaucoup de violences
urbaines
enfin je sais pas si on peut les
qualifier pour mayotte urbaine de
confrontation entre bandes
parfois de manière extrêmement violente
entre de très jeunes gens il arrive même
à se tuer à coups de d'armes blanches
enfin voilà donc nous y sommes très
attentifs
nous y sommes très attentifs pour la la
sécurité publique
ce matin le chef de la mission outre-mer
c'est sa première mission il a été nommé
le 2 novembre sa première mission il est
arrivé à mayotte ce matin voyez des
choses
nous sommes attentifs à ce que nos
collègues de la sécurité publique
bénéficie de tous les moyens disponibles
enfin de la dtp n est bien sûr que pour
le contrôle aux frontières qui est aussi
un sujet important pour mayotte on soit
en capacité avec l'ancienne police aux
frontières maintenant c'est une
direction qui dépend de la dtn on soit
en capacité avec des moyens nautiques
avec un centre de rétention
administrative avec des procéduriers
être en capacité de traiter le sujet des
étrangers en situation régulière et
d'être en capacité de le raccompagner
ses étrangers en situation régulière aux
comores parce que je demande ils
viennent tous des comores dont vous
pouvez être assurés de notre engagement
sur ce territoire sur tous les
territoires ultramarins
on va faire un bilan bien sûr de ce qui
se passe en à mayotte en guyane et en
nouvelle calédonie avec des contextes
très différents selon ces territoires
et croyez bien qu'on va se donner un
petit peu de temps mais on voit bien
aussi qu'il ya des urgences
donc nous allons nous servir de ce qu'on
a observé là bas pour voir ce qu'il est
possible de construire en métropole mais
aussi de nous poser la question
d'étendre l'expérience ddt pn outre-mer
aux autres territoires de notre mère
tahiti martinique guadeloupe réunion et
ça ça appartient bien sûr à la décision
du ministre de l'intérieur
ce secteur vous avez parlé des caméras
piétons je crois avoir répondu un peu à
la fois sur les échéances sur
l'appréciation que nous pouvions porté
sur la qualité du matériel qui est
aujourd'hui à la disposition des
policiers
donc nous ne sommes pas satisfaits du
matériel de cotisation par exemple du
parlement me semblerait extrêmement
utile pour l'exécutif ekwalla n'a pas
tout à fait tenu compte quoi j'en
conclus que ce n'est pas une question
qui me concerne c'est une appréciation
pas directement mon corps qui me suis
dit voilà vous avez posé une question du
sénateur sur les moyens dont peuvent
disposer les policiers pour faire face à
des attaques de plus en plus violente
avec des barres de fer et des policiers
qui s'enfuit sa fuite il recule parce
qu'ils peuvent faire autrement
de quoi disposer t-il réellement
puisqu'on aura enlevé certaines certains
moyens de défense qui existait au
préalable et vous comprenez non mais
vous comprenez quand même que l'image et
kylie a ensuite dans la population qui
vous soutient franchement ce sont des
gens qui vous soutiennent
elle est un petit peu malheureusement
pour la police la police du coup
apparaît comme jeu comme des gens qui
n'ont pas auquel ne donne pas les moyens
de se défendre et je peux vous assurer
que le peuple français du moins dans sa
grande majorité est derrière vous à ce
moment là oui monsieur le sénateur jean
suis comme vous pour vaincus vous savez
il faut parfois se méfier de la manière
dont les images renvoient une situation
et pour avoir quelques années de police
derrière moi et c'est ce que j'ai dit
aux plus jeunes quand je les rencontre
il faut parfois savoir reculer pour
emporter la bataille où la victoire
c'est toujours une question de stratégie
alors les équipements dont disposent les
unités spécialisées de maintien d'ordre
il y à tout type de grenade lacrymogène
de désencerclement il y aller les canons
à eau
il ya l'adaptation de certaines unités à
des types de méthane l'ordre qui varie
selon qu'on le fait à paris ou à laval
monsieur le sénateur que je salue mais
voilà fait on n'est pas toujours dans la
même situation et ce sont des sujets sur
lesquels on travaille en permanence et
il ya une réflexion en cours dont le
ministre a parlé hier soir mais je pense
que tout le monde n'a pas saisi le
peut-être parce que c'était très furtif
la non ce qui a été fait mais on
travaille en permanence à faire évoluer
notre dispositif pour les adapter à des
formes parfois qui ressemble à de vrais
guérilla urbaine on n'est plus dans les
manifestants qui s'affrontent avec d'un
côté on jette des pavés même si c'était
toujours très délicat à cette période on
est vraiment dans des individus rompu et
je réponds à madame la sénatrice qui qui
disait évoqué tout à l'heure la nature
de ces météores avec des individus qui
sont parfaitement identifiés qui
connaissent les moyens de la police les
limites au delà desquelles nous ne
pouvons pas aller les stratégies
auxquelles nous avons recours et qui
s'adapte vis-à-vis pour pour eux c'est
voilà c'est une stratégie pensée
on les trouve à l'ultra-gauche vous le
savez je vais pas jouer les nommer
devant votre votre commission mais ils
ont des camps d'entraînement il est
réfléchi s'ils ont des formations ils
sont aguerris ils n'ont pas peur d'aller
au contact
voilà c'est eux
c'est une forme de guérilla urbaine à
laquelle la police de répondre
aujourd'hui
voyez par exemple sur paris à des unités
qui ont su évoluer pour s'adapter aussi
aux caractères agile de ces agitateurs
qui s'habillent le temps de qui vont
positionner leurs projectiles le
matériel 24 heures avant le début de la
manifestation dans des halls d'immeubles
des endroits qu'ils vont pouvoir
récupérer
oui on pourra la récupérer si jamais des
fous ils sont opérés avant le don qu'il
pénètre tranquillement dans le pays les
bases de la manifestation ils ont
planqué leur matériel dans une cave
quelque part ils ont accès ils se
changent ils ont des sacs à dos une fois
que ça commence à dégénérer il sait
qu'ils passaient capuche tout en noir
ils ont des signaux de reconnaissance
grâce aux réseaux sociaux violence
maximum et une fois qu'on quitte à
manifestation on se débarrasse de tous
de tous ses vêtements et on peut
rejoindre tranquillement au plus 10 mais
là la station de métro et échapper donc
c'est effectivement très difficile pour
la police de prévenir ce type de
situation mais sachez bien que on y
travaille nos services de renseignement
sont mobilisées sur cette sauce et
mouvance toujours très inquiétants parce
qu'elles n'ont d'autre objectif que de
déstabiliser nos institutions
déstabiliser la république essayer de
nous faire basculer vers des régimes
autoritaires et donc tous à la police
sert de rempart face année à des
initiatives de ce type
la sénatrice vous avez parlé de la
question du suffit de la police question
éminemment douloureuse qu'il est
difficile de résumer à des chiffres un
suicide c'est toujours un suicide de
trop
vous avez rappelé les chiffres de
l'année 2019 qui étaient des chiffres
catastrophiques
vraiment je crois qu'ils nous ont tous
touché 1 du du sommet jusqu'à la base
quelles que soient les métiers des
responsabilités parfois on est dans une
forme d'impuissance
ça fait à ces phénomènes
on essaie de comprendre sans pouvoir
expliquer
je pourrais vous donner les chiffres de
cette année qui pour le moment faut
diminuer de manière assez importante
puisque l'on vous disiez l'année
dernière c'est 58 6 2 à ce stade c'est
31 quand un de trop il ya une vraie
volonté de mobilisation autour d'un plan
de mobilisation contre difficile avec
beaucoup de plateformes téléphoniques
qui ont été mises en oeuvre qui
permettent à chaque fonctionnaire qui le
souhaitent qu'ils se trouvent en
difficulté ou un collègue qui observent
qu'un fonctionnaire est en difficulté ou
un chef qui observent qu'un
fonctionnaire est en difficulté de
contacter nuit et jour sept jours sur
sept dispositifs de soutien qui va
prendre en charge qui sera en capacité
c'est déjà arrivé d'orienter même dans
les situations les plus difficiles vers
une prise en charge médicale médicale
urgente
il ya des cervicales un service de
soutien psychologique ssp aux
opérationnels qui sont des psychologues
en place au niveau central et au niveau
territorial à l'échelle des zones qui
interviennent dans des situations
particulièrement difficiles notamment
quand des policiers sont blessés ou pire
tu es pour accompagner l'entourage
professionnel entoure un jeu l'entourage
familial on se livre aussi cette année
parce que je pense que il faut pas non
plus considérer qu'on parce qu'on a de
meilleurs chiffres qu'on a gagné la
partie ou qu'il faut s'endormir sur nos
lauriers
donc on a confié à une société
extérieure le soin d'auditer notre
système de prévention contre le suicide
voir ce qui marche qui marche pas ce
qu'on pourrait améliorer
voilà mais je vous confirme que c'est
vraiment un sujet je redis douloureux
pour la police c'est que nous avons pris
un brave à bras le corps ce président
vous avez gardé le meilleur pour la fin
si j'ose dire vous avez évoqué la
question de la clé d'étranglement
effectivement que vous aviez mis sur la
table au moment où j'avais été
auditionnés devant votre commission le
rapport de monsieur lowe's a été rendu
j'en ai donné communication monsieur
miné de l'intérieur qui a souhaité sur
la base de ce rapport que je puisse lui
faire un certain nombre de propositions
d'ici la fin de l'année
on vous disant ça je ne vous parle pas
du fond je vous parle de la méthode mais
vous comprendrez que je ne puisse pas
m'exprimer sur ce sujet avant que le
ministre de l'intérieur des faits mais
voilà il ya un certain nombre de
diagnostics de constats qui ont été
posées dans la par un groupe qui était
constituée donc à la fois inquiété
dirigé donc par le directeur des trains
est composé de formateurs de
représentants des organisations
syndicales mais deux représentants
spécialisés sur ce domaine des gestes
techniques en intervention il y avait le
médecin du raid
un médecin légiste et des sportifs de
haut niveau spécialisé dans les sports
de combat il y avait un judoka de très
haut niveau voilà est donc un rapport a
été rendu qui voit là je veux pas
prendre la responsabilité d'en révéler
le contenu mais avant que le milieu
intérieur ne les faits comme ceux
présents je pense merci monsieur le
directeur général pour toutes ces
précisions
il me reste maintenant à a levé la
séance
en vous remerciant de des questions qui
ont été des questions qui étaient posées
et naturellement des réponses que vous y
avez apporté leur a sans doute d'autres
occasions de pouvoir rpt débattre et
peut-être que vous reveniez à l'occasion
des textes qui ce qui se présente à nous
dans quelques semaines dans quelques
mois
tous les cas
bonne continuation
[Musique]